como interpreta a estas medidas del
gobierno de daniel ortega contra
universidades y asociaciones vinculadas
al sector educativo cuáles cree que son
los objetivos que persigue
muchas gracias santiago y buenas noches
a toda la teleaudiencia de france 24 así
es el día de hoy nuevamente el régimen
de daniel ortega a través de una
asamblea nacional o un congreso
totalmente controlado por ello pues
despojo de su personería jurídica a más
de 15 asociaciones entre algunas
universidades y organizaciones de
sociedad civil vinculadas a la iglesia
con el trabajo humanitario
particularmente el tema de las
universidades nos preocupa pues es un es
una nueva arremetida contra los jóvenes
contra miles de jóvenes que están en
estas casas de estudio y que pretende
demonizar y centralizar el control del
régimen en estas universidades
particularmente lo poli que es la que tú
has mencionado universidad politécnica
upoli que fue un bastión y es un símbolo
de lucha y de resistencia de los jóvenes
y de los estudiantes en cuanto a los los
sucesos de abril del 2018 entonces
nosotros como jóvenes e integrantes de
la alianza cívica por la justicia la
democracia que hemos sido como es la
contraparte frente al régimen de ortega
en las 2 mesas de negociaciones en 2018
y en 2019 pues condenamos este acto no
que nos parece ser una nueva embestida
en contra del futuro de los jóvenes de
miles de jóvenes y que además hoy fueron
esas 15 espero anteriormente ya ha
habido aproximadamente 5 universidades
más que han sido despojadas de su
personalidad jurídica real y hablando
del futuro de los jóvenes contanos cómo
se ve afectado el movimiento estudiantil
y también todo lo que es el sistema
educativo nicaragüense por las políticas
de ortega
si ellos lo que pretenden hacer con esto
es centralizar y armonizar el control
más de lo que ya lo tiene pues en las
universidades públicas ellos tienen su
brazo represor que unen y que además
jóvenes y estudiantes que se
involucraron en las protestas del 2018
un centenar de jóvenes han sido
expulsados de estas universidades y han
quedado en el limbo en cuanto a su
formación académica superior pero además
es una
una embestida a la ley 580 que es la ley
de autonomía universitaria y ya como te
decía pretende cercenar la libertad de
cátedra y de pensamiento que existía
particularmente en estas universidades
que son privadas no porque las que
fueron despojadas el día de hoy todas la
universidades de tendencia privada y que
ahora pasan al control del consejo
nacional de universidades que la parten
gubernamental que rige las universidades
dolly brevemente nos quedan menos de un
minuto pero no quiero dejar de hacerte
la siguiente pregunta porque todo esto
se da cuando comenzaron ya los juicios
contra más de 40 opositores detenidos en
lo que fue la previa
presidenciales y esto por supuesto
delitos contra la constitución y la
soberanía entre ellos hay representantes
del sector estudiantil verdad cuál es su
situación actualmente
en efecto entre ellos hay jóvenes y
estudiantes del día de ayer fueron ya
fueron declarados culpables dos jóvenes
entre ellos muamar ya hacer el día de
mañana al estar alemán que es uno de los
dirigentes de nuestra organización
también va a tener juicio igual el día
11 de febrero máxime crees que el
presidente de nuestra organización todos
estos son jóvenes que desde el 2018 se
han comprometido en la lucha por la
libertad la justicia y la democracia y
por regresarle a nicaragua un futuro que
nos ha sido arrebatada por este régimen
que se ha instalado de manera
totalitaria estamos a la expectativa
sabemos que van a ser condenados pero no
vamos a dejar de luchar por su libertad
porque ellos son inocentes de limoná
muchísimas gracias por estos minutos con
france 24 n